adjust the leading coefficient and
vertex coordinates to make the blue
parabola match the orange parabola
now we've already seen how we can go
about shifting these parabolas if we
subtract something from y it actually
shifts the parabola up by that amount
and we've already talked about that in
the video on shifting and scaling
parabolas but let's actually see it in
practice because this is actually going
to allow us to experiment so we'll see
if we increase this that's actually
shifting it down
while if we decrease it it shifts it up
but we actually do have to shift it down
for this example now at least the y
value of our vertex is vertices look the
same
and similarly similarly when we shift
the whatever we're squaring whenever we
if we shift if we subtract a value here
it shifts it to the right while if we
add a value here it shifts it to the
left and let's verify that so if we
subtract a value here it shifts it to
the right and if we add values here it
shifts it to the left
so just like that it looks like i've
been able to get our vertices to
coincide this vertex right over here is
at the point x equals negative 4
y equals negative 3 and it's no
coincidence those are the values that
make x equals negative 4 makes this 0
and y equals negative 3 makes this a 0.
but these parabolas still don't match up
this yellow parabola seems to increase
faster so the scaling factor right over
here seems too low for our blue one so
let's increase it
and there we go if we put a two there
went fast it went it's it's growing fast
enough if we put a three that's growing
too fast
if we put a 0 there it's a flat line and
then it becomes negative so let's bring
that back to just positive 2
and we're done